foreign
people welcome to the Honest Trailer
commentaries for Ant-Man quandomania
yeah
um we're talking about that movie that
came out and Danielle's here hi Danielle
hey how's it going I'm back to you uh
still in my closet with now I have my
hoodie covering all of my uh cleanliness
sins so perfect yes it's all my Amazon
boxes with my address all over them so
I'm sending this image to room Raider
right now they'll get back to you soon
time for an intervention I really do
need this thing to start working again
anyway hi hey ants um if you've never
seen this show before
um hello we're going to start with where
you been yeah where you been um we're
talking about Ant-Man 3 quantumania
we're gonna give you a blow by blow an
atom by Adam dissection of this film it
blows it blows there's your there's your
one Blow by blow we're gonna watch um
we're gonna watch deleted scenes we will
take your questions and comments to put
those in the chat and we'll respond to
them and then uh tease you with next
week's honest trailer
I'd need to refrain from teasing it up
top because I always just want to give
it away right away let's wait till the
end
um because it's got a great ending much
like next week's film ah you did you did
you bastard you bastard
um so Ant-Man what a yeah okay fine
let's turn off the distractions I don't
actually don't have a script on here
today anyways let's just talk about I
don't know how I'm gonna do the comments
or questions yeah
but Ant-Man 3
I had High Hopes I'm an Ant-Man Defender
I've said no Ant-Man slander before on
uh on this very desk because I liked
Ant-Man one and two I think they're they
have been in the past a necessary but
but forgive the pun sort of weightless
diversion from the rest of the MCU and
its Grand architecture storytelling
Ant-Man was a chance to slow things down
to do things uh that were more
self-contained and one of my favorite
genres I do like heist movies I did like
that they had that aspect I do like Paul
Rudd much like everyone with a pulse and
I thought that there's like these were
the few MCU comedies that like actually
had good jokes in them they Veer they
were funnier than most of the mcu's
attempts at humor
um I found his Supporting Cast
delightful they've gotten rid of all of
that folks
it's dirty pond water era where they
need to shrink them down to to enter the
Star Wars world and try to save the
universe for the next seven phases and
just what a what a what an unforced
error or maybe a forced error where
they're like feige's like it all rests
on Ant-Man now where this could have
just been another fun Ant-Man movie and
here we are with the with the weight of
the Universe on his shoulders and and
it's just it just done been dropped
um but that I think this is like the the
general consensus right or do you guys
disagree oh no I hated every moment of
this uh it honestly feels I feel like
the quantum realm itself is a big part
of the problem it's it's disgusting it's
off-putting it looks gross it's not it's
not like you know how we talk about the
uncanny valley where like you can make
you can make something look real but
then if it looks almost too real it
looks gross and weird and it's got to
look like somewhat stylized I think the
same is true with busyness on screen
like you could make a background look
busy up to a point and it's impressive
like Avatar 2 where you're like my god
look how rich this ocean environment is
there's Coral there's all this detail
but if you get if you take it up if you
do it the wrong way there's too much
detail in the background it becomes
gross and impossible to to even like
what is going on it just becomes like a
big brown blur look most Marvel action
is uh or Daniel you you talk first
because I'm gonna go on a rant about
Marvel action uh Danielle talk um I
the the problem with the it's the same
thing that everyone else is saying is
that I think that we all thought it was
neat that Ant-Man did have this larger
role to play and the events of endgame
and that the quantum realm actually
wound up being something that was really
important and I think maybe the wrong
lesson was taken away where they're like
oh you like all that Ant-Man science so
let's really lean into the Ant-Man
science on this one it's like no we let
we all liked end game because it was
like the end of 10 years of movies it
wasn't because we were all like oh man I
gotta go I gotta watch that end game not
for all of the satisfying conclusions to
like this tale they've been telling for
a decade but because I want to hear more
about ant science like no one was asking
for more of this like we we wanted all
of the things and that worked before and
I 100 we've always said we enjoy when
these movies can flirt with not just be
like being two genres like being a comic
book movie and a heist movie and the
comedy did work and I really really
really miss all of his ex-con friends
um
feel them missing and they've now been
replaced with
um
I guess
yes
clearance yeah no I prefer Louise to
Blobs of mucus yeah you've really you've
knee kept uh the strength of Ant-Man
which was uh his crew and his sort of
Outsider status in the MCU but
especially the setting and what that
does to the action because I thought the
other cool thing about those films was
the action scenes played with scale in a
way that was really fun and
understandable like that he's using cars
like roller skates or oh he's on a train
set but it looks epic like that was
inherently a fun place to set action
scenes and made them stand out from the
usual CGI blobs that Marvel movies
devolve into in the third act this was
all blob all blob all the time yeah
everything looked like a paramecium and
if he's growing really big or really
small and fighting something with like a
bunch of cilia sticking out of it I'm
trying all my bio yeah really nicely
that's really good
it's the little hairs in the back
but and everything looks like
looks like yeah already our conversation
is getting kind of disgusting the whole
movie is disgusting it's it's I I really
don't I really feel like they like Rick
and Morty obviously Rick like all of the
MCU now owes a debt to Rick and Morty I
think the guy who wrote this is a Rick
and Morty veteran Rick and Morty is a
cartoon so like when you make a
disgusting mucosoid blob it doesn't look
gross because it's a drawing but when
you do it in this movie and everybody
looks that way it's just off-putting it
just aesthetically unpleasant yeah you
could have done a gross out R-rated
version of this movie I still probably
would it would have worn out it's a
welcome from me after 20 minutes or so
but yes but better
who's that nepo baby director
um wow you're gonna have to get more
specific crush the Futures kid oh
Brandon Cronin yeah he's good though
he's great I don't want a bash Brandon
Christ it's not a bash I'm just saying
he could have made a really disgusting
yes everyone's got a messed up face yeah
exactly yeah yeah if you're gonna cover
anything everything in Lube like
actually get some lube and like make
some wet puppets use those holes yeah
it's all eight of those holes there's a
there's a joke where Michael Douglas to
fly the ship he's gotta sticks both of
his arms in these like mucus tubes and
he makes a face and that's my review of
the movie his repulsed face oh I gotta
stick my hand in there it's like I gotta
watch this for two hours that was me
well we have to watch this for about six
seven minutes so let's roll the honest
trailer for Ant-Man just read
quantumania and the WASP yeah
Burying my head in my hands this whole
time just imagine that all right let's
go
where did I put the script for this
episode I don't know from the anarcho
Communists sending hidden messages to
children that only your most
conservative Uncle can decipher and the
director of Back to the Future the ride
so pause uh we got that wrong
um slightly the co-writer yeah he wrote
back to the future of the ride he
directed uh a whole bunch of other the
Animated Series they had live action
like wrap arounds he directed those so
apologies to Friend of the show Peyton
Reed um is he a friend of the show he
did come on here to react to Ant-Man one
I'm sorry but that doesn't buy you any
favors clearly clearly clearly not a
friend of uh part of the show friend of
others no but he's he's obviously
welcome to come back on and call us
idiots or or yeah tell the truth yeah
yeah about um about what really went
yeah yeah what happened yeah anyways
back to the future of the ride fantastic
if you ever get a chance
um it's probably the third no it's gone
now right oh yeah The Simpsons Ride is
now where Back to the Future once stood
where do you think it's Back to the
Future the ride were an action set piece
set in the MCU I think it'd probably be
like in the top five
it's pretty good yeah they you have to
bump your DeLorean into a dinosaur I
believe that's right see you don't get
stuff like that in in these movies yeah
um okay just that you have to bump your
mucus into Phil Murray's mucus okay keep
going I can't stop saying I won't that
ditches the low stakes appeal of Ant-Man
in favor of an infinite Loop of King
movies
[Applause]
so Jonathan Majors plays all of them too
late to change that in post huh Google
and man in the WASP Quantum media uh
what to do with Jonathan Majors what's
uh I actually think this you got a real
you do with a problem like a managers
sorry
I think you've got a great out because
he's already had multiversal B you could
have one throwaway line of like I got
tired of that face yeah you know and
like so I don't I don't think that's
going to be an issue okay and I want to
pitch Coleman Domingo Coleman Domingo I
think he'd be a great newt New and you
new king all right uh you have a new
king or a king tank Daniel
um I was I wanted to go with the uh
Yahya uh even though I know he's real
busy with all the comic booking but then
uh me and Lon texted and he said Coleman
Domingo and I was like justice for Zola
yeah and then so so I'm kind of on the
Coleman to me because he's got he goes
that man can shoot some scenery good
yeah Zola he goes great from like oh I
this guy's kind of fun I like this guy
to like real scary and like that I feel
like that's the same Kang that's to say
like oh this this guy might be he kind
of seems trustworthy but oh no he's
terrified like I feel like that Coleman
Domingo could do that all right yeah
yeah would be great but he's gonna he's
about to be Wonder Man in the MCU so
yeah yeah which is also I mean he's
super Charming
he's not a role model he's told us no
he's not a robot and like imposing a
physically imposing specimen Charles
Barkley uh okay keep going
in a world where the same effects team
has to balance this and wakanda forever
at the same time comes the theatrically
released collection of storyboards where
every actor looks copy pasted into their
scenes
reacts to absolutely nothing real
come on
and wanders around a stomach turning
world of British Brown pond water come
on
he's been 200 million dollars on this
and it still looks like gritty's
colonoscopy
we have some alts for that
yeah
it's true though that's that's I think
the main weakness of this film is the
way it looks yeah oh for sure it can't
be overstated how muddy and like like
you're in a dirty fluid medium um and
how unexciting and unappealing they made
the quantum world and then would throw
in stuff like like oh there's a Cantina
like oh and there's also a fancy
restaurant and there's gangs and like
it's the opposite of World building it
is literally just like here's bits and
pieces of other bits and pieces of other
movies right it had that we're gonna fat
feel of like they didn't really put
thought into how this world works or
what it's like to live there it's just
occasionally you'll see flashes of like
here's our fancy restaurant here's the
building that's alive or you know and
then yeah and there's like that
Barbarian leader or whatever she was and
she's like they've destroyed my people
and like I can't see like more than six
feet ahead of me because it's all Pond
scum
conquered our our village like it's a
village what do you farm yeah can you
eat the grass the ground yeah how did
you even all get here and why do no two
people look a lot like why do people
have the same species like what what is
going on well and it almost looks very
flat like it does I you know I know that
people rag on the volume and I didn't do
the research to see if that's where this
was done but it does look like a bunch
of people who are standing in front of
the movie while the movie plays behind
them yes um and I would actually go to
the quantum room which I didn't actually
go to the quantum realm but I would like
it to feel like they did
um I was watching because I guess I've
been saying English so it was like oh
you must want to watch William uh
William Harper Jackson uh and more stuff
and I was like I do so I was watching
the good place and they have a couple of
these scenes where it's like you know
this really isn't that far off in terms
of like the believability and like how
much you feel immersed in the world as
Ant-Man does except that they do it for
two seconds for a comedy TV show you
know that was on like basic and this is
a big old move the thing is yeah again
it's not the lack of ability of these
effects houses it's the lack of time
that they're given because they
literally if you read that article they
were pulled off of Ant-Man quantumania
to work more on
um not just the sheer amount it's it's a
limited time to do a ridiculous amount
of Animation I mean this was basically
an animated movie there's very little
that's live action in a lot of these
sequences so yeah they're given these
huge Vistas to animate in these really
narrow windows but that no wonder that
mistake came so early in the process of
like what can't we just do an Ant-Man
movie where he takes a trip to the
quantum realm in the third act like
otherwise he's in San Francisco with
Luis like I feel like we're we're we're
like you know because there was a core
of that movie of him and his daughter uh
like she's an activist he's like he's
done he's hung up his his thing he's
just kind of cruising like a celebrity
she's like no there's still problems in
the world there's a movie there yeah I
mean you could definitely I feel like I
feel like in retrospect even probably
Peyton Reed I feel like would probably
agree like Kevin feige if they we had
them right here and they gave him truth
here and be like should we have set less
of this movie in the quantum realm like
probably yes like they can resolve
things in the quantum realm but let them
have the movie in the world it's a
reverse Masters of the Universe the
master of the universe we only get like
10 minutes in Eternia and then it's all
of the parking lot behind a chicken
restaurant this is the road we should
spend more time
man in a chicken restaurant parking oh
yeah yeah last time well and you know
what
them getting pulled off of this to do
black panther is their version of
getting the lights turned off during the
last scene yes
thank you yes that's exactly it
you can have good they must own guildor
somehow yeah they can have grilled or
Escape
who owns a three-part scream Jackie's
docu series owns Guild maybe we could
buy gildor can we go we crowdfunding
literally own Guild or people's
franchise
kill door one Guild door two
return dark gildor
um we'll go Christmas special yeah all
right keep going
next year
I heard Steamboat Willie version of
Mickey Mouse is hitting public domain if
Disney allows it to go like we'll see
what yeah
they'll still go after anyone that makes
like uh Steamboat Willie Fast and
Furious or something yeah I feel like
they've gotta they've just planned keep
your eye out for for our next feature
Phil Steamboat Willie yeah okay keep
going
author now or at least famous enough to
leave all his day one homies behind back
it up
okay
now he just wants to be a good dad
because hopefully the third Cassie's the
charm Cassie Lang is the mcu's fifth
canonical child science genius your
daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement doing what
anybody would do in San Francisco woke
stuff you shrank a cop car what was I
supposed to do look the other way hope
has returned with nothing new to offer
besides her tactical Hobbit hair Janet
Van Dyne is back to vaguely hint at all
the quantum sex he had in the quantum
realm I had no idea I know it's
we'll talk later she
never said anything about you well I
don't think I would have told my kid
either wild stuff I had needs and
Michael Douglas is never too stoned to
wander around and talk about ants for a
paycheck science
with ants
and science uh this just makes me
nostalgic for that Ant-Man one promo
ants
truly the most honest trailer of them
all yeah sure
it's they've got such a great cast yeah
such a great cast all funny people in
this everyone's funny everyone's super
talented and the the movie is just about
getting the bubble door down to the down
the uzi what's it and then retrieving
the retrieving the magic crystals so
that Kang can enter the nth Dimension
yeah she she mentioned uh William
Jackson Harper a great really funny
actor great a good place really good at
Midsummer just utterly wasted here and
like a one joke One Beat character like
his bit he's he's a psychic but there's
every psychics bit is like ew that's
gross that what you're thinking yeah a
little bit I mean they kind of do like a
little bit of like the SNL like trivial
psychic like he's kind of Captain
Obvious like they're afraid and it's
like they're screaming but they don't
lean into it they don't make it a bit
you kind of have to get there yourself
yeah
um but yeah just when you have this the
cast they've assembled is so good and to
give them just nothing to do uh
character-wise or emotionally except
just kind of wander around the goo world
yeah there's so much more focus on goo
world than there is any of the
characters or any who is Kang who is he
who's Kang what's he gonna do yeah well
they that's weird too that you could
tell that this was being workshopped in
an era when they thought Kang would be
more of like a cool reveal like they
didn't know that Loki would have already
happened I guess and we'd already have
met Kang they seem like they're making
this movie thinking they get to
introduce Kang for the first time
because the whole half the movie is like
we have to get ready what were you doing
here Janet and she's like I can't see
right and it's like you guys know we met
this guy already in a TV show was it him
was it Jonathan we know he saw he's also
in the cold open you two were together
in the first two minutes it's that guy
it's not that suspenseful all right here
we are keep going running into the
quantum realm and join our heroes on a
desperate search for a reason to make
more MCU movies as we all trudge through
a half-assed orb Heist fetch Quest
that's just an excuse to set up the next
big villain him you left all of us
with him he's looking for you they are
talking about Kang right not from me and
not from him he is the future yeah we
met him in Loki you don't have to be coy
about the name oh
for him it's not a big reveal he told us
who he was he's in the cold open uh
whatever Jonathan majors does off his
best Shakespeare in the park boys that's
what conquerors do as this once powerful
refuses to accept he's been canceled
and choose scenery like a gun knows that
he's going away for a while so he better
stretch each line as long as possible
what are you going to do
him anytime win
I was just saying that's a dramatic
pause you don't have to pause it there
are enough spooky aliens don't you know
a Rick and Morty guy wrote this one too
with new characters like Captain Obvious
everyone
is disgusting Bill Murray trying to be
the fun Cameo that Jeff Goldblum was but
Trends closer to another Ralph boner
boner
and the not ready for Prime Time Modoc a
floating joke with a grave warning for
illumination Studios do not even think
about making a live-action Minions movie
Modoc I mean modoc's a fun character we
all love Patton oswalt's Modoc
um do we it was fun it was fine I love
the idea
I if everything else in the movie was
not a joke that joke would be okay right
but the fact that everything in the
movie is goo and ridiculous it doesn't
play it just Blended in just everything
else it wouldn't stand up exactly yeah
thank you yeah Justice for Modoc I guess
some people were really cranky and it's
like it's still Modoc like I'm okay that
they're not taking Modoc seriously it's
still a big floating head like we're
fine at the same time I thought the part
that I had a problem well yeah I don't
it's not that that was always the
replies like well but it's supposed to
look stupid like oh okay well like well
you know it's supposed to be a joke like
oh okay but it just doesn't it doesn't
match anything around it and so it
doesn't play yeah it looks like a sketch
or something like that but and if you
can't do Modoc don't do Moda right that
I think that's what it comes out to is
like if there's actually no way and I
don't I don't think this is true but if
there's actually no way to take Modoc
from the comics and translate it in a
way that's fun to the movies that looks
cool just don't you got a million
characters yeah
all right keep going just make them wait
make them wet like everything else
in time with the Ageless Paul Rudd is
always a treat settle in for a universe
that's gotten so big it's starting to
collapse under its own weight that
should have kept Ant-Man as the
refreshing after dinner man instead of a
dance floor salad to prop up the next 30
of these dumb things ah can we just skip
to the new Fantastic Four I'd rather
watch Louise recap the rest of phase
five I'll see if that's complicated
because when I first see another story
small ride Hope Floats The Mask Stinger
Ant-Man original recipe
netwoman Kanger issues the midways Kirby
sneeze land lord krylar with musical
guest ants Booker henchman at my house
my house broccoli Rob
and Mr E from the band eels because his
real-life dad invented Multiverse theory
in a 200 million dollar movie why he's
there
witty committee
how many owls do you have he has seven
holes
oh wait are you sure there's seven I
think that eye hauls would count no did
the math and butter count as one for
being connected what about the separate
peel for girls oh [__] you for making me
do whole math
I'm embarrassed by how much time I spent
I couldn't stop my stupid 80d ADHD brain
like the instant that that started I was
like okay I have to pause and now the
next hour is just gonna be whole math
like I really between seven and nine I
really disagree we'd be contingent Ike
listen the eye hole thing I don't I I
get it I don't necessarily agree but I
think there's a debate to be had there
about whether those counties yeah
because they're filled they're sockets
they're they're filled holes they're
filled holes but they are holes the I
really disagree with your mouth and
butthole wonderful attention
it's a straight line and it's there's
curves it's it's a it's a whole morass
in there it's not it's not a clean dude
no real tunnels have curves
those are two those are two distinct
holes I feel very strongly
you're sending a slack and you're like
how close can I get to describing what
I'm thinking without getting super fired
right I'm saying it's either Seven and
you're certain safe slacks and a certain
other not safe so yeah the Honest
Trailer slack is a safe one it's a safe
space it's a safe slack yeah yeah
there's um yeah yeah I I it's we all
agree it's between seven and nine though
can we just agree on a range well no she
she yeah it's between seven and nine I'm
saying it's either seven or nine she's
allowing for a potential eight and I'm
that's where I'm alive I'm alive I am
allowing for a potential Aid I just
don't I just don't like the finality of
he has seven I think that that that
deserves for it more where where's Mr
eel's dad
and if you get your ears pierced new
hole I would I was yeah that's true new
hole piercings yeah technically well no
they don't go in they're they're clean
through they go through that thus
forming a hole right but it's a whole
India body not just a whole through you
know yeah
yeah like it's an opening how many holes
do you have let us know in the comments
below
I was so proud of myself by the way for
recognize like I did not look up that
that was Mr E from the eels that's
purely like 90s indie rock fan and maybe
like
beautiful Blues yeah from the road trip
soundtrack wow there you go Stifler
lives
um all right uh who else was in that
Stiffler uh oh yeah breckenmeyer reckon
Meyer yeah Tom Green obviously sure
um and then that other guy there was
like that there's the there's oh DJ
clothes
there's
the snarky Jew guy who was in a few
other like 90s things that I'm blanking
on his name yep we'll find it we'll find
it um you know uh show some uh outtakes
story
Mac and mini me Paul Ryan Paul Van dime
Hopi Changi phasing hope Small Wonder
the cast and the Furious twig Newton big
little guys fatal subtraction basic
insect Magic Mike
xxs damn it Janet Zab and Granny sir
majors
Time Lord Exile on King Street do you
mind Professor lowercase x actual polka
dot man bigly goo Peter schrankman
Ghostbusters after
thoughts
now probably I don't know VeggieTales
Modoc no problems honey the kid shrunk
me
Quantum [__]
cool title design as always I have a man
who likes to be understood not me I hate
that I hate being understood I am a man
who likes to be understood amazing miss
me with that uh you know what I'm
writing me up there's a random line that
Adam West says on Family Guy okay he
goes and I am a man who loves his Taffy
and that's what that the delivery on
that for whatever reason that's
immediately what I thought of
um we're not done yet but I want to
pause to thank you all for watching this
far
um you might like a video we also
released on this channel today um do box
office bombs kill careers uh it's it's
actually an interesting study we did um
on a new episode of by the Numbers uh
you'll see exactly how much of a hit to
your future movies prospects both in
budget and um your order and the credits
and stuff like that after releasing a
film that makes less than half its money
back it's interesting because we do we
you think of there being like a bad
movie is like a career killer but in
most cases you could think of directors
get to come back and make movies after
flops yes and no it's like actors
recover fairly well yeah directors are
the ones who get hit the hardest
director flops are but it's still you
could still think of like you know like
Josh trank did that Fantastic Four movie
that's hated like he came back and did
that that out what is it Capone or
something Al Capone the uh obviously
your career does not dial though we do
find some exceptions where it's like
even like Troy Duffy you did Boondock
Saints and like uh there's a documentary
about his flavor he got to come back and
do more yeah but it is the we Quantified
we were we got a guy to run the numbers
on exactly what percentage drop you have
in your next project size and typically
what your what your um how much of a
reputational hey you take as an actor uh
after release so you can you can climb
your way back there's people who've
recovered multiple times no women just
men yeah
you get one shot as a woman it's like
well done I don't know how you did it I
don't know how you did it so check out
that video there so there's some cool
info in there
um and now we already did the outtake so
let's get to some questions and I got I
just gotta say right off the bat
apologies for a long time viewer Adam
Holbert I was a CG artist on this but
I'm not gonna hold anything against this
this meaning what all of our [__] on
it that we've just done if you bring
that up though because it is worth
pointing out again this isn't a knock on
the talent of the behind the scenes
people working on the movie we all know
that they could have done a great job if
they had the right amount of time to
actually work on the movie and finish
their job so this is not a knock on the
individual VFX artist it's all about the
the budget the schedule this is this is
feige this is down to five they turn the
lights out on you while you were filming
Skeletor
this is Bobby Iger Kevin feige this is
this is out of out of the the Adam
Holbert level people it's crunch yeah
it's the it's the um necessity to get
these done as they're announced in time
for some quarterly earnings report
exactly the fact that it even got done
at all is a Herculean achievement and
then just to get crapped on by us who
who did nothing and know nothing must
not feel great but it's not your fault
sorry also not your fault that they
decided to set this movie in goo world
yeah like it wasn't the end here's your
inspiration disease yeah they were just
like here make this this next guy also
look like a booger like can I can I make
him look like something other than a
booger no Jokers are funny booger make
them look like Rick Rick talks to
boogers yeah everything should look like
you licked a bus bench and then and then
uh can you be can you be a talking
pickle no then it's a booger those are
your options yeah uh and how would you
fix the VFX problem uh more time like
more five more years yeah more time more
money not rush these out yeah that's all
yeah that's and stop overworking the VX
folks because I know their Crunch and
everything is
um y'all were working ridiculous hours
and I know that there's not a whole lot
of family uh life balance going on there
go go to James Cameron's office show him
what you've got and be like how long do
you think Jim they need to to whip this
into shape and then whatever he says
give them that amount he's gonna say 11
years
[Laughter]
one Ant-Man every decade
relaxing but it's gonna make two billion
dollars that's right
uh so let's see uh what should we talk
about next
um Evan J pretzer do you have any real
life colorful x-con friends my favorite
is my friend psychotic Pete who went to
jail for selling fake Supermarket
tickets
that's a low bar for being psychotic
Pete yeah
you gotta stab at least one guy yeah
come on psycho Pete you do better
um x-conference I know I I I do know a
guy who is it is an ex-con he went to
different for hacking stuff you I
believe he like hacked people's eBay
accounts and like stole stuff from eBay
or whatever but um uh so yeah so that's
that's that's a that's a viable
x-conference nice is that mine are all
my family members and it's sad because
either in my family you either
yeah every time a Radford is Born the
gods flip a coin
yeah
some people want to go for 20 something
years you know like the whites of West
Virginia the local sheriffs I'll check
in they're like all right new Outlaws
uh Adam Preston asked thoughts on the
Marvels trailer looks cute I thought
that you know what's her name's the the
um the most exciting one Miss Marvel
um of that gang uh I mean I really could
not care less about Spectrum internet
service provider or whatever her name is
like floating around don't care call
Spectrum it's time to call Spectrum tell
them you uh you want Corn Pop TV Carol
Danvers I don't like not in a not in a
thumbnail Brie Larson kind of way but I
just find her as a boring kind of a
boring character so far I feel like it's
so hard to tell with these like like I
the concept sounds fun it looks like it
might be fun but I don't I don't know
are they gonna blast us off to goo world
again are they gonna let it be a movie
like I don't know I don't know I'm at
this point I feel like I'd give up on my
ability to tell ahead of time whether
I'm gonna like one of these yeah fair I
thought I thought I was gonna really
like that Thor one we were all I was
crazy looking forward to Thor and then
yeah what a letdown yeah and then this
one too I thought would sounded fun Thor
love and thunder was really like my like
fantastic Beast 2 for the MCU where I'm
just like oh no yeah
yeah those two to get Thor 11 Thunder
and then this is really like don't
forget eternals I didn't mind the
turtles that much I didn't know it
wasn't but it was like
Doctor Strange too I'm fine with all
those none of those made me like doubt
the core like I like MCU movies none of
those shook the foundation but these
last two Thor 11 Thunder now quantumania
I'm like oh man maybe I am kind of
losing my my desire to see more of these
yeah
um okay final question uh loose
Valenzuela what job would be the worst
to have in the MCU
I mean he goes on to say if you want to
be in stem the bar the bar is set to be
Tony Stark and any other good paying job
is kind of a nightmare yeah I mean MCU
people's minds must be so shattered at
this point because they've if you think
about what they have experiences like
the Earth is almost all their friends
disappeared for five years
there's an alien head talk about the
eternals like just like rising out of
that you found out the Earth is an egg
you just would feel your sense of
stability utterly I mean we think about
things like you know the the pandemic
and inflation and like real world things
that make people feel unsafe and
insecure and they're so small compared
to what's happening in the MCU that
there may be inadvertently laying a good
groundwork for whatever
um X-Men you know proto-fascist movement
is gonna be like let's get rid of all of
these superheroes yeah he's like okay
yeah I feel it seems like they brought
nothing but problems I do have an answer
for this question uh guy selling pizza
balls on the street you're gonna get
a lot of abuse coming your way look out
I was I was gonna say either bus driver
or train operator because I don't know
how
[__] the nearest bus or train so
that's just gonna be one of those things
we was constantly wearing like armor
just in case it's like oh great someone
cut my bus in half oh yeah your bus is
getting jacked
and so yeah they're jacking your bus
is the only time that will show sympathy
for bus drivers let me have this
uh there should be a superhero bus
driver that's uh that's that's missing I
mean there's a superhero name right
there villain yeah
super villain all right we've done
enough on this uh muddy mess we've waded
through the goo to bring you to get to
the end it's like it's like it knows
it's gross though right like the movie
leans into being discussed sure why why
is that the thing it's so weird anyway
finish up I'm sorry
well you look at things like under a
super intense microscope like they look
like sometimes they can look cool like a
kaleidoscope or like it's like it's
supposed to look like a slide like under
a microscope yeah I thought yeah like
microbes like where you see the little
things squirting around in there it's
gross gross but if you go to spoil it
like looking inside a pond like looking
inside a toilet that's what I thought
the whole thing was supposed to be bad
choice
um make it a look at a crystal look at
something cool
um speaking of uh things you don't want
to look at yeah looking into like a
Muddy Pond here's something you don't
want to look inside uh next week's movie
yeah because if you open it up and take
a look you might find something that you
don't like and uh yeah that's our clue
uh you'll see it um in a predictable
number of days from now that's your
second clue and we'll see you then on
Australia commentaries thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you